We want to go back now to Ilya Ponomarev,
who is
I said, is the former Russian State
Duma official
who left
because of the invasion
by his country of Ukraine.
And is currently
opening a new television
channel to try to counter
Russian propaganda.
So first,
let me ask you,
Ilya, you've been on our show shortly
after the war started, after your nation
invaded its neighbor, Ukraine.
And you've seen today
the so-called victory day parade.
How do you analyze what it looked like?
It was seriously scaled back.
There have been headlines saying
that it showed Russian weakness,
not Russian strength.
How do you assess
Oh, indeed.
I think it's a significant scale.
Back just 45 minutes.
That's the shortest military parade
of all times that were happening in
in Russia. And they say so many.
Vladimir
Putin was obviously
afraid of a drawn attack.
So he's surrounded himself with hostages.
He took other leaders of his countries
to protect him
because he was sure that
Russian Partizans would not fire
in the circumstances,
not to provoke a major
international conflict.
And still here was a
he was afraid
and also
parading war and not for the diverse
Russian military entities
because they mostly perished
that the field of war.
But for some military students,
and some Kazakhs which were unseen before
anyone one tomorrow.
Can you just let's
just let's just dove
into what you just said
that he was afraid of a drone attack
and he had hostages.
And you say from other CIA countries
that is,
you know, the commonwealth
the countries that
broke away from the Soviet Union are now
independent countries.
You said he was afraid of of an attack.
By what?
By you said Russian Partizans.
Who is he afraid of
whom?
As you have seen on the third of me
in the night,
there was attack on the Kremlin's door
by two drones
that were fired
from the outskirts of Moscow.
And the source of this attack
was Russian resistance.
And the reason for this attack
was to actually force
Vladimir Putin
to cancel the parade altogether
so that Russians would understand that
the war is lost.
How do you
stop?
Stop for one second is really important.
I'm really interested in your
in your sourcing on this,
because, as you know,
the Kremlin blamed Ukraine.
They said it was a botched
assassination attempt.
Obviously, Ukraine denies it,
but you have specific information.
How do you know is the Russian resistance
Obviously, the Kremlin
is producing a lot of fake news
and one of these fake news
that it's Ukrainians behind the scenes.
And by the way, you know,
the masterminds were
Ukrainians were the Americans
some that that was them who was behind.
But obviously
about what kind of assassination
can you speak of,
which is an attack on the door
of the main building in Kremlin.
First of all, nobody knows where
which one stays and in particular,
whether he is there.
Secondly, he was not there,
and that was an known information
for everyone.
I know
and I know this because I was speaking
to people
who were preparing this attack
a month ago
and at that time, the
they started preparing
and we were discussing
whether it's the right idea
to do it on the 9th of May.
And they was advising against
because they were saying that,
first of all,
that would put civilians in danger.
And secondly,
because it's such a cycle, B
for Russians that
that may achieve the opposite result.
So they decided to make
this attack beforehand
to try to force Putin
to cancel the parade altogether.
So basically,
you're saying on our air on CNN
that you were involved
in this drone attack or at least in
in talking to the people who did it,
that the Russians, Russian resistance.
So what is their aim?
What is their full aim?
I would like to stress
that they are not taking the credit
in organizing this fantastic attack,
although I think it was a great show.
But definitely, yes,
Russia resistance is growing.
It's behind many attacks
already inside Russia.
There are at least thousands of people
who is involved
in the resistance inside the country,
and that's not Ukrainians.
And they're trying to stop the war.
So these are brief anti-fascists of today
and they are doing their best
to actually save
the owner of their country
because most of
the Russian position left the country
and the resigned from the fight
And these people are still fighting.
Okay, so
so that so so the question is then,
because that's
what everybody wants to know
and you seem to be
in touch with people there
There still is,
according to Levada and others,
which I know operate under strictures,
but seemingly overwhelming
support for President
Putin there still are people there
in huge numbers
who are going to war to fight for Putin
and who are being recruited
and who are answering the call.
So what is the actual state
of people's belief in this war?
Russian. So
you know, people
who are going to war
are the fight for Putin.
They're fighting for money
because Putin puts all the country
into a complete misery.
And still,
majority of Russians
are living worse than they were living
during Soviet Union times.
So they are struggling for their survival
and they're
taken to
whatever money is available there
without thinking.
What does it mean
to actually go and fight against
such a close friends,
former friends, sons and former
brothers and sisters, sisters
or for Ukraine?
So that's awful. But it is a fact.
But if we look inside and look at what
people are actually supporting this war,
actively supporting this war,
then we will see that it's turned
15% of Russians
who are standing
on those imperialist positions.
And there are 20, 25% of Russians
who are standing in
on active antiwar position.
The rest is just the swamp
we are telling this.
It's all the just
whatever the they think Mr.
Putin wants to hear
because they're simply afraid.
So can
you tell me what you hope to achieve
and can you achieve with your new channel
that's designed to counter
the Kremlin's propaganda?
And let's face it,
they have every massive
tool at their disposal, state media
and everything else.
Everything else is shut down
inside Russia.
Well, obviously,
we are right now pretty small.
We are we have 400,000 of subscribers
and approximately 8 million
or four monthly audience which
which is nothing being compared
with the scale that we need to achieve.
But at the moment of the change,
we hope to be the source of information
because we are linked
to the Russians
who are actually fighting.
We are linked to Russians
who are fighting together with Ukrainians
for fear of the field of war.
And we connected
to those resistance groups
which are fighting inside Russia.
And we saw an example
in Belarus of project
called Nexta,
which played the key role in
protest against
President Lukashenko
just three years ago.
And so we hope to take the same
with our approach.
And finally,
I know we've talked
about the Russian resistance,
but do you believe,
according to the Pentagon Papers
that were leaked
and you've seen
what Prigozhin has been doing,
you know,
yelling at certain members
like the defense minister
and and the commander.
Do you believe that there is infighting
or differences
within the Kremlin, within the Russian,
you know, chain of command within
Putin's circle about this war?
Obviously,
there are a lot of internal problems
and there is a lot of internal fight
and there is a fight
going on with everyone.
And there are four fights
between political circles and Kremlin,
and there are fights
between business circles.
But the reality is that the
overwhelming majority of Russian elites
I would associate
like 90% of Russian elite is right now
position minded in terms of this war.
They want to stop the war.
They want to escape.
They want their personal wealth.
And they're looking for this way
out there
right now, competing to be the first
to find this way out.
So there is very little loyalty to Putin,
and that's
why it's our job together
with the countries of Rammstein Coalition
is to propose them with we out
and then the regime of Putin
would finally collapse.
And very quickly, what is the way out?
How does it end
They need to defect.
They need to switch sides.
They need to
start supporting Ukraine in this war.
And so they need to start supporting
Russian resistance,
which is pretty obvious.
But for this,
we all need to say,
yes, we want the regime change in Russia.
We don't want Putin to stay in power
and we don't want to let him select
anyone to replace him.
We want the fundamental change.
Ilya Ponomarev,
former member of the State Duma,
thank you for joining us from Poland.
And we will
thanks for having to check in with you.